whoa what look at the definition of the
ridges on his muscles
there's like a lot of subtle things
going on here that are kind of blowing
my mind right now the most noticeable
thing is just how saturated the green is
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to see how
you can get three months free
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
we got niko we got clint we got myself
wren here and today we're going to be
looking at a bunch of different visual
effects
some hulk shots from different movies
that have the hulk in them and comparing
the technology the things it did and a
whole section of effects that you've
probably seen before but never in this
context
let's get started
is this journey to the west it is
journey to the west nico
dude it's budget gandalf no thank you
excuse me what look at the veins on that
leg is this an entirely cg foot it's
gotta be
wait why did it make the veins and the
veins just disappear and the foot comes
out of a different spot
wait what wait roll that back wait it's
like halfway through the art direction
they're like okay the foot gonna
materialize right there
and the veins grow and then the foot
doesn't actually
interesting interesting dude all of the
hair on that leg too
i know it's it's it's too real it's
really well done
[Laughter]
dude i love this foot clench when he's
like he gets serious he's like
yeah all right so how do you think they
did that well definitely
with reference they had to have
referenced an actual foot clenching
you can see how the skin actually like
flexes up over the knuckles and bones
when the foot is flexing and you see the
veins bulge a little bit as like the
blood flow increases
that's not something you can just do
with basic animation that's something we
need to start using
either like surface displacement where
you are raising and lowering the
geometry based on a texture map and an
artist is just dialing it in by hand
there's no sense to build a full system
of like muscle and bones for this one
shot we can probably have an artist just
kind of go in
and like move the mesh and the geometry
by hand
[Music]
i think they probably filmed that for
real how would they have got him up do
you think he's on wires
luckily we got a little bts clip to beat
us
we got to beat his clip oh he's on a
stilt and wires
so it's straight up all the motion
notice how the dudes are wearing blue
screens
it's like one of the most overrated
things on
hollywood productions is putting someone
in a green screen suit
is so unnecessary he includes them yeah
but they're going to rotoscope him
anyway
you're right and you'll notice in the
shot they have been landing and the
actual shot they're slightly different
they rebuild the geometry of the
background roughly so they can reproject
the image
so they can animate him a little bit and
animate the camera a little bit
differently to give you like this leg
shot basically where the camera goes up
over him so with the exception of the
main actor this entire shot is cg
even though it's from a real plate that
plate is projected onto the geometry
and then re-rendered so in essence
that's new cg
it's because they didn't actually have
the foot there on set when they filmed
the shot
so they kind of sweetened the camera
angle to show the foot
in its best light basically exactly yeah
it's like it's hard to compose for
something that doesn't exist
it's usually easier just to recreate the
[Music]
shot
yeah this is a little fun one for you
guys another stephen chow clip
[Music]
okay kung pao enter the fist it came out
in 2002
this is an 18 year old movie it can vote
now this is just a weird movie
it's a great super weird it's so good
there's one thing that really stood out
to me having looked back on it is that
this has some
incredible blue screen comping so they
bought the rights to a really old kung
fu film and then
put steve odenkirk into the entire film
and they did a really good job with it
to the point where it's like it doesn't
immediately
register as being an old film with a new
guy put into it i thought they filmed
the whole movie
just as is yeah see that was the thing i
mean they do technically
film a bunch of original stuff for this
movie and you can actually kind of tell
because it has that newer aesthetic to
it like less green and whatnot
but there's a huge chunk of this movie
that has just repurposed old footage and
they comp him into those shots
it looks really good dude there's like a
lot of subtle things going on here
that are kind of blowing my mind right
now you have to paint that guy out which
means you have to paint back in
the guy behind him who's moving around
also they're matching like the film
stock to it that's the thing that's
craziest to me is
like they are matching the quality of
the film stock like perfectly
this shot right here when he actually
attacks the guy they do something really
interesting here they utilize
his arms that go in front of his head
and they use that as a transitional wipe
they actually just film different plates
with his angle static and set up
perfectly it's just very classic cut it
out stick it on the footage
that's it also they set up the lighting
perfectly on set when they recorded this
stuff it's like
the best thing you can do for matching
blue screen or green screen footage
is just make sure your lighting setup is
as close as possible to the stuff that
you're going to comp into
it is basic they're doing basic effects
here but they're so effective
yeah they're doing so well the hand of
the artist here is very deft this movie
has so many bizarre sequences in it
though like do you remember the whole
cow sequence
oh boy oh my god [ __ ] chick-fil-a
commercial
oh jeez dude remember this is 2002. this
is like
that's pretty funny everything about
this is just utterly ridiculous utterly
ridiculous that was good
okay are you ready for the most
referenced vfx shot of the early 2000s
oh my god how do you think they did that
though this is just he's on wires and
they're running around with a camera
he's just
pretending to be in slow motion yep
that's the easiest way to do it is to
fake it
the thing that made the matrix bullet
dodge scene so good is the fact that
he's actually moving at full speed
in real time but because of the camera
setup they actually are able to make it
real slow motion
it's the coat that made it yes yeah
whereas in this movie
he's just like literally hanging on
wires like i'm in slow motion
so kung pao was actually super inspiring
to me back when this came out is in 2002
is like at the height of sam and myself
just doing vfx on our home computers and
kung pao
is like the most basic of vfx techniques
it's like it's a dude shot on a blue
screen and then like cut out and stuck
into the footage and that's it and like
it was such a great demonstration of
just like how much magic
you could make with after effects 3.0
and your pc
it's just it's such a just a great
demonstration of like this is what we
could be doing
the limit is in our computer the limit
is just our technique in our imagination
and our storytelling experimental type
stuff
the second movie with the hulk was the
incredible hulk starring eric norton
edward
edward norton that's what i see eric
norton
now this is officially part of the mcu
it's the second mcu film to ever come
out right after the first iron man and
they made
some more creative changes for instance
there's a lot more like
surface detail in the skin of the hulk
and he's a lot more like a rugged look
and he's a lot more mean looking
man look at that muscle yeah dude the
veins the muscles like he flexes and you
see like the muscles flex and whatnot
so he actually looks less photo real
though yeah than the 2003 one
he looks like a video game cinematic
character
fine dude that's how the army deploys
they have ramps
whoa dude that smile did anime hulk it's
like devil may cry they're definitely
putting a lot more effort into like
having character in the face but it's
still just generic character it doesn't
resemble edward norton at all
like they gotta drop the beat
this is so cool so now that i'm actually
seeing this like the thing that stands
out the most about this hulk is just how
stringy his muscles are yeah like you
could see every individual strand going
across his chest
and through his freaking deltoids and
triceps it's like so much muscular
details
it's got an aaron jaeger titan vibe
going on here's the biggest difference
i am seeing between this and the 2003
hulk
they are not really worrying about
photorealism anymore
what do you okay i mean i'm not saying
they're just turning off all their
shaders and just rendering them out with
some polygons like they're still
making him look good but it's much more
painterly and animation based
than it is trying to make it feel like
this is real it's on set the lighting is
accurate and sometimes he looks real but
more often than not he looks like an
animated character you know it's like
the sun's always edge lighting him
whereas in anglies hulk the sun is not
always edge lighting him
the sun is accurately placed and the
first hulk he's very
front lit a lot of the time just very
flat but when you're more edge-lit you
get more definition with the shadows and
whatnot
i think saying not being worried about
making it look real is a little bit of a
harsh thing
obviously taking that into account
they're prioritizing a stylized look
rather than
pure photorealistic scenes you're right
you're i am oversimplifying and
because at the end of the day they're
still trying to make something look
realistic that is still the primary goal
across every single shot is to make it
look like it's real
even if it's slightly stylized to look
better hyper real that's the thing all
this stuff looks hyper real rather than
realistic so how does mark ruffalo
stack up against these other two hulks
the biggest change from the first two
movies
to the avengers was the fact that they
actually modeled the hulk
to look like mark ruffalo dr banner
now might be a really good time for you
to get angry that's my secret captain
i'm always angry i'm always hungry
that's the line i'm always hungry
so somebody on the street came up to me
like i watch all your videos i mean
that's really cool
how do you watch all my videos have you
subscribed yet they turn around to me
they go
that's my secret i'm always subscribed
and they walk away
so you can be like that cool person
who's also like the hulk and subscribe
to our
channel please
still pretty green yeah i'm actually a
little surprised because they made a
whole
point of being like we desaturated the
green to make them look more realistic
but i think the green is actually more
saturated in this scene
than in the incredible hulk
so still super detailed but i feel like
the physics in the muscle structure is
much more like accurate to
an organism now like you can see his
muscles on his shoulder blades twitching
and flexing look at the definition
of the ridges on his muscles like on the
left side of the screen there
we go see that is super realistic
looking to me they actually have like
that poor detail across all of his skin
it looks like he's wearing one of those
airplane neck pillows
i'd say that there's less muscle detail
in this version of the hulk than the
second one but it looks better in this
one yeah the second one was like a
little too maxed out for me on the
muscles you know yeah a little bit too
much
like i'm in a muscle competition
[Music]
they spent a ton of effort on the face
yeah the biggest
change is just all about that face they
have so much more like facial animation
points here
it looks way more like mark ruffalo it
looks more like a realistic person
within this green character it's a very
realistic final result
so that was like the first mark ruffalo
hulk right and it looks very good and
they continued to improve
the little aspects of them as the movies
went on let's talk about
avengers end game which had the most
rufflized hulk
all right we all have our assignments
stay low keep an eye on the clock
so there's the original hulk from the
2012 avengers do you think they grabbed
the old model
you would think and they actually
thought that like okay we could just
reuse the original model but
all the technologies surrounding that
had come so far they couldn't
reuse the original hulk asset so they
had to remake the original hulk as close
as they could
to the original
maybe smash a few things along the way i
think it's gratuitous but whatever
this hole looks just looks like mark
ruffalo so between the two final
avengers movies
basically bruce banner figured out how
to merge his personality with hulk
i put the brains and the brawn together
and so they became
professor hulk the idea is that he's all
of bruce banner's smarts
with the hulkiness of the hulk i mean he
would de-hulk to like go to sleep and
like
no did he build him did he build a new
house did he does he have a new bag he's
rich man he lives in a freaking flying
aircraft carrier
all right like you can really see the
detail in his face now like that is
absolutely 100
mark ruffalo with a green texture over
him now essentially right
obviously it's all cg but it's so driven
by the original mark ruffalo and of
course they actually have mark ruffalo
on set
for pretty much every single scene and
so he's actually being there acting with
all the other actors
and they just completely replace him
with the digital version of him it's
pretty standard practice in these movies
but it's just so much more finessed and
detailed now that all of his little
micro movements are actually coming
through now yeah you're getting like the
crow's feet wrinkles on the sides of his
eyes
yeah so the first two hulks look nothing
like the actor that drove them but then
even within the mark ruffalo versions of
the hulk they get more and more like
mark ruffalo throughout the course of
the movies yeah clint these movies
aren't bad you should watch these are
actually pretty they're good movies
i'm gonna say it the mcu movies
specifically the adventurous ones
are works of art and they are
achievements in film and if you call
yourself a filmmaker you deserve to show
them some respect
look ant-man sure buy the books whatever
the iron man 3 buy the books whatever
but the avengers movies are
works of art by some fantastic we're
literally making clint yawn
i mean honestly for the much like as
much crap as you guys give me for not
watching them i think it'd be easier if
i just watched them so you guys would
just stop giving crap yeah if you
subscribe to the channel
you'll get clint to actually watch in
gaming you can't make me do anything
right okay fine it's really cool to see
how technology has changed just in the
last 18 years
of making marvel movies alrighty now it
is time to talk about expressvpn what is
a vpn you might ask whenever you are
connected to the internet all those
bytes you're sending out can be
intercepted and read by third parties
and you don't want that you want to have
privacy when you're communicating with
the internet so basically a vpn just
creates a secure little tunnel that
blasts through the internet that no one
can penetrate with their
hacking abilities and of course
expressvpn is the best one out there no
joke i actually legitimately used our
coupon code to buy
expressvpn like i actually legit did
that because i needed one i also used
another vpn in the past and it was so
slow but the nice thing about expressvpn
is that it's actually really fast
so let's say that there's a show that
you really like on a streaming platform
for instance you cannot watch
rick and morty on netflix in america but
you can in the uk so all you gotta do is
just change your location
within expressvpn and voila you can now
watch every episode of rick and morty
so do as i literally did and go to
expessvpn.com
corridor crew and you can get three
months for free when you sign up using
the link in the description
check it out now back to the video hulk
smash i've been kind of enjoying doing
these like comparison moments
one thing i want to do is compare
spider-man 2 to spider-man 2 to
spider-man 2.
we'll do that soon but i want to see
what suggestions you have
the more we do these the more difficult
it gets to find
really juicy clips so if you guys have
any sort of recommendations for us
things to look at please leave a comment
down below
we love reading them and they actually
inform a lot of the clips that we do
pull for you guys but thanks for
watching it's always a fun time doing
these with you guys
yeah next time we do them every single
week so i'll see you guys next time